hey uh what's uh what you reading there
champ just doom just i've never heard of
just dune why aren't you laughing yeah i
want to read the series one more time
before the movie comes out what could
they do different that hasn't already
was done better in the 80s okay back
then they just let an insane person make
a movie and we were fine with that we
were fine with it we had sting you kids
these days are spoiled beyond belief
hey can you get me a beer while you're
up when did they start printing words so
small
this is my idea of a good dune remake
james cameron he quits doing the avatar
movies because those are for the liberal
snowflake crowd let's be real 50 sand
worms they can all transform into cops
they go back in time go to new york city
they hire 50 cops real cops working
class guys you know what i mean union
guys and they get arnold schwarzenegger
and they don't age him they make him old
all right fine i'll watch the stupid
trailer uh it's not gonna be any good
so two tickets for friday night yep all
right
[Music]
you